Coffee on a Tuesday in block 34.
Uh,
so you're annoyed with me?
Yes.
I did drop out of the university there
for a few months with no explanation,
but I can explain it in 2010.
I graduated from college as a film major
and I was sure sure then that I was
going to be a filmmaker for the rest of
my life that summer I made a film called
I met you once in a dream and I thought
then it was gonna be the next in the
line of,
you know,
hundreds of movies,
but that did work out in the next few
months.
I read a lot of philosophy and wrote my
discourse on truth before leaving Boston
with three friends to take a u shaped
road trip across the country.
And a blue Hyundai Tucson.
Oh,
I miss that car.
I moved to Portland,
Oregon with small teeny tiny crisis of
purpose.
Worked on a farm for a little while and
came out the other end.
A novel.
I grew a beard.
Oh,
I missed that beard.
I wrote my first book,
Big City,
which you can still buy on gumroad.com,
and I left Portland when everyone I knew
left it to that.
I was in la for a little while before
moving to Paris where I wrote my second
book,
all languages,
the rose,
which is either dying or dead and when I
came back to the states I moved back to
La and try to figure out how to public.
One day when I got lost in a youtube
wormhole,
I happened to discover the Vlog brothers
and I thought the videos were pretty
fucking cool.
I figured out that John Green was a
novelist and he was selling out
printings because of his subscribers on
youtube and I thought,
you know,
I can do that.
So I did.
I started making videos every week with
an eye towards publishing my books,
but after awhile I just started to want
to make good content for its own sake.
I really liked this youtube thing.
One day I was in a cafe and I had this
idea for a video for the project for
awesome on the kind fund charity for
getting kids desks in Malawi,
which was actually created by the last
word with Lawrence O'donnell on MSNBC.
The video sort of blew up and they heard
about it and then they had me on the
show.
The night after I was on Lauren's email,
ben asked me if I wanted to go out for
coffee,
so I said yes,
yes,
yes.
He said you should move to New York and
do this video stuff for us and since I
was broke and since I was working as a
telemarketer,
which was crushing my soul into tiny,
teeny,
tiny little bits of sharks,
a tiny,
tiny little pieces of glass that were
cutting me from the inside and since I
was broke and this was basically a dream
job,
I accepted.
It.
Took a long time to work out the
particulars and then working them out
and I disappeared from this blog,
moved to New York City,
sort of working at 30 rock for MSNBC.
Doing this video stuff would.
You can sometimes find here and here
links in the way and now that I've
finally settled in,
I sort of want to kind of come back.
Can I come back.